ما الذي تتعلمه عن هذا
الانفجار الغامض في ميدان اختبار أسلحة روسي
يتضمن مواد مشعة على
ما يبدو أن بعض الأشخاص الذين يعملون هناك
قد ماتوا ، نعم تعلم أنه أحد
تلك الأشياء التي كانت الرسائل في
كل مكان بالفعل من قبل
السلطات الروسية  لقد
غرس الكثير في طريق الثقة
على المستوى الدولي بالطبع على
المستوى الوطني وكذلك ما تعلمناه هو
أنه قبل يومين كان هناك
انفجار كبير في منطقة اختبار
على ما يبدو على سفينة في شمال
البلاد في القطب الشمالي شمال
البلد الآن في الأصل ،
قالت السلطات إنه كان
محركًا صاروخيًا يعمل بالوقود السائل أو وقودًا سائلًا ، وهو محرك صاروخي هو
الذي انفجر ، ثم انتشرت الرسائل بالفعل في
كل مكان ، حيث قالت ناتالي من
جهة ، أولاً وقبل كل شيء ،
قالت السلطات إنه لم يكن هناك ارتفاع  في الإشعاع
وقالت السلطات المحلية نعم
كان هناك ارتفاع طفيف في الإشعاع
لفترة وجيزة ثم
تم حذف هذا البيان و  قال العسكري إنه
لم يكن هناك ارتفاع في الإشعاع الآن
ما تعلمناه على
مدار 24 ساعة أو نحو ذلك هو أنه على ما يبدو قتل خمسة
أشخاص يعملون في شركة نووية مملوكة للدولة في روسيا
في ذلك
الانفجار وحول ذلك الانفجار.
تقول السلطات الآن أنه
يبدو أن بعضها قد طار
في البحر ثم تم العثور عليها ميتة هناك في وقت لاحق ،
ومن المؤكد أن ذلك أثار بعض
الأسئلة وأريد أن أقرأ لك
بيانًا صادر عن هذه الشركة
راسل له وقال إن المأساة
حدثت  خلال الأعمال المتعلقة
بالدعم الهندسي والتقني
للمصادر النظيرية في نظام الدفع السائل ،
لذا فمن المؤكد أن هناك شيئًا
مشعًا يحدث هناك بالطبع
أحد الأشياء التي نعرفها ناتالي هو أنه منذ
حوالي عام ونصف ،
خرج فلاديمير بوتين وقال ذلك
تريد روسيا تطوير ما يسميه
صاروخ الدفع النووي ناتالي الذي يعمل بالطاقة الإشعاعية